[Music]
what could be Irish is just my kind of
silly its low-budget corny knows it and
has a ton of fun with it
the story centers around a boy named
Kyle who seems to be the luckiest kid in
school he always finds money he makes
the finishing shot on the basketball
team everyone can't believe how things
always go his way but one day at an
Irish festival his lucky medallion is
stolen and suddenly all his luck seems
to be disappearing but not only that a
lot of our strange stuff is going on his
mother starts to talk with an accent
he's getting shorter there's a little
point on his ears growing his hair's
turning red and on top of all that his
parents refused to tell him about his
heritage as you can guess Kyle discovers
days hath leprechaun and the medallion
that was around his neck is actually
magic that was keeping him human the
whole time so the search is on to see
who stole the medallion maybe one of the
kids or his angry grandfather or who
knows on the surface it doesn't seem
like there's a ton you can really do
with this story but they seemed to take
advantage of it pretty well not only is
there a fair amount of Irish lore though
I don't know how exactly authentic it is
but the writing has some good lines and
clever ideas and the actors all have
good comedic timing so many of these
lines could easily crash and burn but
these actors are really trying and doing
a good job making a lot of these jokes
hit I mean come on they were smart
enough to cast lassie from psych in
there they must know what they're doing
but film doesn't go quite as far as an
idea like this should probably allow I
mean it would be nice to see more
leprechauns more of a fantasy world and
so forth but for the most part they just
keep it in the real world there's only
one part where they actually travel and
even then it's at night and kind of hard
to see but I get the feeling this was
kind of on a low budget and honestly for
the budget they have some of these
effects are pretty good this is 2001 and
for a Disney Channel TV movie to have
effects that look this good it's
actually kind of impressive
I should also comment that I like the
way the movie is shot I mean it's not
amazing it doesn't try to show off or
anything but a lot of the shots always
have a little bit of motion or an angle
or a visual style to it
yeah it's nothing visually breathtaking
but you can tell they're constantly
trying to say how can we make this shot
look a little bit more interesting than
just doing a medium shot or a
straight-on shot they do have fun with
those close-ups and tilted angles but
they never
go too far to where it's distracting
either if I did have a problem it's that
the last third slows down a little bit
you almost think the climax is gonna
happen this one place and then suddenly
it changes to a basketball game and yeah
it's a basketball game it's not like
there's a ton of laps you can get there
I mean they try but you know how these
Disney movies go they want look cool
during the basketball game not exactly
get a lot of laughs but it more than
makes up for it with some out-of-the-box
thinking for example there's a scene
where they're trying to find these
thieves that stole a bunch of gold they
see a rainbow and obviously they say it
must be at the end of that yeah it
doesn't work the way you'd think where
rainbow lands and gold is just gonna
appear the gold is already there and the
rainbow follows that it's kind of clever
thinking the movie is full of nice
little touches like that that are
exactly nice lappers but still get a
chuckle add on top of that actors
they're legitimately charming I enjoy
watching Plus a story and direction that
didn't have much to work with but still
did its best and get my interest I think
this is a cute little adventure but on
your green hats or whatever other Irish
stereotypes you're fond of and dance
your way in for a viewing
you